today we'll talk about cm3 which is a
model that directly ingests websites
learns the html it uses a novel
objective that does left to right
language modeling but with a twist that
essentially allows it to incorporate
bi-directional information into the
language modeling it incorporates text
structure images hyperlinks and with
clever prompting it can do almost
anything it can do what daley does
generating images from text it can
caption images it can do text
summarization it can do entity linking
and it can do much more i like this
paper because of the idea of
incorporating the structure of html and
also the new objective is very cool so
we're briefly going to go over what the
paper is and does and how it works and
then we're going to jump into an
interview with armin who joined me in
talking about this paper is a very
informative interview and i suggest that
uh you give it a listen so this is just
going to be a short introduction again i
have to rely on you to tell me how i
make the best use of authors coming on
because i think it's so cool i want to
talk to them about the paper and i want
to get the most information out there
for you that is possible so please tell
me short intros long intros how to
structure it and all leave a comment
down
if you like videos like this leave a
like as well
if you leave a dislike you know that's
kind of useless now on youtube but you
know feel free i'm still going to see it
so cm3 a causal masked multi-modal model
of the internet by researchers at meta
i'm going to guess this is now
so
this model is it's a family of models
actually and a family of causally masked
generative models trained over a large
corpus of structured multi-modal
documents that can contain both text and
image tokens in fact much more so what
this model does it's a language model
and the language model ingests html a
cleaned up version of html but still
html if you don't know what html is html
is essentially the language your
websites are written in and it consists
of tags so for example one tag is a div
tag that is it's it has it had i think
it had a meaning at some point but right
now it just serves as kind of a
container tag so div might be something
like a container and you close it by
saying slash div
anything in between is the content of
that div other popular elements are for
example a paragraph so inside a
paragraph you can have some text hello
there
and then what you can also have is
hyperlinks so hyperlinks start with an a
tag so you can see these tags can be
nested these tags can have attributes so
the a tag can have an attribute like an
href so that is a url so www.something
and so on so it can have urls it can
also have urls within the document then
there is the text of the link now we
close the a tag oops
we may continue the paragraph or we may
close the paragraph
a forward slash and the last thing that
we're also going to need in these
documents right here
are images so there can also be images
and i'm going to write this over here
after all white space doesn't matter in
html so images can have a so-called
source the two most important attributes
are the source and the source is it's
usually usually it's a url it can be a
base64 blob but usually it's also a url
like uh i don't know like inger
gerd.com
somethingsomething.jpg
so the browser would actually go and
fetch that image and display it at this
position and also
an important thing is the alt text which
you put there for screen readers and and
other sort of
assistive technology that cannot
directly make use of the image to see
what's in the image
so you can already see here that there's
a lot of information in html now
previous work what they would have done
is if it's a language model for example
gpt3 they would simply only take the
text bits of that they would take for
example here hello there they would
probably also take the text of the link
right here and and that would be it they
would scrape the websites for the
containing text to do language modeling
other models such as dali dali i've made
a video about dali if you don't know
what it is but essentially a model that
you put in uh text and it gives you an
image and the reverse of that is is sort
of clip not the reverse but clip is a
model where that says whether or not an
image or a piece of text go together
well and the reverse of dali would be
like a captioning model you put in an
image and you get a text describing that
all of that you can get by also scraping
the internet and always taking the
following two things you take the alt
text of a an image tag and you take that
source image and these are pairs of
images and text that go together right
so you can train this is kind of like
weak supervision there are some problems
with that but it's weak supervision uh
likewise there are other tasks if you
are for example doing entity linking or
entity um
entity disambiguation or something what
you would do is you would go to
wikipedia and on wikipedia you would
always take the text
of a link and the link itself if it
points to another wikipedia article and
you know in this case here it says like
romans were captured by alexander the
great alexander the great would be a
thing you could click on and then that
link would sort of tell you what entity
that is it'll lead to the wikipedia page
of alexander the great so people have
parsed websites for a long time in
various ways to achieve different tasks
to collect data for different tasks
however there is this new direction and
it's not the first paper that does this
but it is the first that i've come
across and the previous work is also by
largely the same authors so i'm just
gonna give them credit uh for some at
least some of this the the the novel
idea here is that why don't we use the
entire structure of html directly in
instead of just scraping subset of them
now again they do clean the html because
a lot of html is kind of like visual
elements cascading style sheets and so
on there definitely would be information
there but it is a good step to say hey
the whole thing you know the entire
thing here
the structure that is actually super
duper important it has so much structure
that we would throw away otherwise for
example the image right here
you know it could be not only described
by the alt text it could also be
described by like the surrounding text
like this stuff right here of course if
there's an image on a website reasonable
to assume that the surrounding text
might also have to do something with it
right
it is reasonable to assume that in order
to disambiguate this entity right here
you might want to take a look at the
text around it you might want to take a
look at the images around it and so on
so if we had a model that could directly
learn the structure of html we could
exploit
all the work that went into creating
that html which is essentially what
front-end programmers and and website
programmers do all day this is human
ingenuity that goes into creating these
structures even if it's a framework
right that there's something someone
that has to come up with you know what
are the elements how is the structure
and that is that is really good data and
exploiting that data to me when i saw
this it made perfect sense to say you
know we should just keep the html and
just learn the language model over the
html
right so what can you do if you have
such a language model well if i have
trained such a language model i can
maybe you know start a paragraph i start
a paragraph i put like a piece of text
right here all right
and then i just start an image tag
and i say source equals
and then i let the model generate
whatever is here right now there is a
there is a there is a trick right here i
can't obviously put a url i actually
have to put the image itself there but
if the model is good enough it will look
at this
it will generate an appropriate image or
you know if i could do the same thing by
simply having an image tag
and first generating the alt first
putting the alt text i put something
here that i want and then source and i
say equals and then i let the model
continue it will generate me an image i
can reverse that i can put the image
first and then say please generate me
the alt text i can put an entity and say
please generate me the link to the
entity and so on so you can see how
powerful this is
we can do many many different tasks if
we have a model like this
the this is one thing that this paper
does um and i said it's inspired by
previous work however uh it pushes it a
bit further
um so first we have to discuss this and
then we have to discuss the novel
objective which makes it even more
powerful
so the only thing to discuss right here
actually is
how do they treat images because
language modeling is fine i can just
have an appropriate tokenizer for html
which needs to be i guess a little bit
of a different tokenizer than for uh
regular text because you have to handle
these tags correctly
but essentially i have to have a
tokenizer and transformers are pretty
good at learning to to open uh sort of
appropriate tags and and then close
appropriate tags again and so on the
only part really are the images so we
don't wanna we don't want to have urls
of images in there instead what they do
whenever they encounter an image tag so
whenever they encounter image with a
source
that equals some url www.something
what they do is they would go they would
fetch that image they would put it
through a i think a vq gan model
some vector vector quantized
gan model
that is pre-trained
they would extract the latent uh the
latent z the latent embedding
uh that yeah the latent embedding from
that and they would put that embedding
here so these models these vector
contest models they would take some
image and have like a neural network and
they would encode that into
a series of tokens which are going to be
something like i believe it results in
256 tokens
latent tokens so these are essentially
because it's vector quantized
every one of these is a part of a
vocabulary
and so these are essentially tokens like
language model tokens like letters that
i can build images from
i can simply unroll oops and simply
unroll the tokens in these images that
the vqgan gives me
right i can have some scheme of how i go
through here and i can replace the
source property here just with the m
with these tokens
or i mean appropriately the embeddings
of these tokens all right this and this
goes here and so on
so once i have these tokens right i can
train the language model and then the
language model will generate these
tokens again again they're not image
they're not continuous values because
it's a vector quantized model they come
from a fixed vocabulary and that's what
i ingest and that's what i predict and
therefore i can treat it exactly the
same as the language model there is a
bit of a difference with how these
things are distributed they do talk
about this in the paper as
language tokens are zipping distributed
and image tokens are by design uniformly
distributed but i mean essentially from
a conceptual standpoint it's the same
the second thing they do is they have a
different objective than language
modeling language modeling goes usually
goes left to right so
that means the language model whenever
it generates a token it looks at what
it's generated so far and then from that
it will generate the next token
and what it cannot do is it cannot look
at the like right like the the head it
cannot look ahead you can't tell it you
know here is a piece of text and here is
a piece of text please fill in this
piece of text that would be a masked
language model like bird
but some a model like bert isn't really
good at autoregressively generating text
for that the left to right causally
masked language models are much much
better and you know a higher higher
performing so is there a way we can get
the best of both worlds or at least some
kind of a trade-off turns out yes there
is with the following objective so as i
said we have an example right here in a
standard language model we have the
following the following thing which is
a way we can do entity linking right so
imagine imagine we'd have to predict
this piece right here
so as you can see this is the link it's
an it's an anchor tag this is the link
to the page the wikipedia page for
american
sorry armenian armenian nationalism okay
so armenian nationalism we want to
predict that link
which is essentially solving entity
linking for this sentence if we only
have a causally masked language model
all we can do is
is input this piece of text to the left
so this would be our entire context now
this example is constructed such that
this thing right here right this word
right here is really important to
classify to seeing what is there
therefore if we only had a causally
masked language model if we only ever
trained left to right we couldn't make
use of the word that was behind right
here
if we had something like a masked
language model we could absolutely do
that so that is this example right here
if we had a mask language model then we
could absolutely um
we could do that we could input
this and we could input this and we
could say you know here is a mask token
please generate what's in the mask token
however we already discussed the
weaknesses of that approach instead they
have a new objective which they call a
causally masked language model oh
i
i called this before causally masked
language model because there's also this
sort of causal causal mask inside of it
i'm sorry the causally masked language
model is the thing they are going to
propose
inside of these language model usually
there is something like causal masking
so it's a it's a bit confusing uh if i
look at this right now
what they do is during training
so during training what the mask
language model would do is it would just
mask out these parts and then it would
try to fill them in this limits training
because you can only mask out so much
you can't train in parallel and so on
whereas with the auto-aggressive
language models
you can train a lot of stuff in parallel
there is no none of these noise and so
on everything's everything is decomposed
nicely
here what we would do is we would take
the things
during training we would simply have a
span that we mask but we don't just
leave it away we actually put it at the
end
so and there is an identifier token
right here to show you can see that this
token right here and this token right
here are the same so we tell the
language model we tell it look here is a
sentence okay there is a mask right here
there's something missing it could be
one or many tokens and then
here we want you to generate that thing
again
and the model simply has to generate the
thing back here there can be one mask
tokens there can be many of these mask
tokens in which case we just you know if
we mask something else like this right
here we just put the corresponding token
right here and ask the model to generate
it on the model will learn if there are
two mask tokens the model will learn to
after it finished the first uh thing
that it's supposed to produce to
automatically
put a the next mask token there
so that is that is the objective it
still benefits from this left to right
thing
as you can see we can train this left to
right once we reorder the sentence we
can just input the whole thing here into
training we can train it like a decoder
only language model and we get all the
performance off of that
yet we can still do kind of like masking
so we get bi-directionality by design
because now if we want to predict this
mask right here we have seen all of this
context so essentially we have seen the
whole the whole data point we do
sacrifice like a little bit
of performance
because well inherently this part here
is still left to right so there's that
like in itself it's still left to right
also we do take stuff out of order so
there is the question of you know how
long can i memorize stuff and so on with
transformers maybe a bit less but we do
take stuff out of order which introduces
some noise and so on so it is definitely
a trade-off wherein pure language
modeling is still going to be more
powerful but this now enables us this
enables bi-directional context
essentially into the things that we
generate and that has a lot of
advantages for many many different tasks
so there is a whole scheme it's it seems
to be really important how exactly oh
yeah 256 tokens for each image see
um sorry
it seems to be quite important how you
generate these masks during training how
long they are they try to make them
quite long in order for the model to
learn important structure and so on
we'll go through all of this in the
interview um
the scaling laws are pretty pretty
astonishing in that their large model
right here and these are large models
right these are like the the scale of
this
uh it was trained it was trained on
384 a100 gpus no i think that's even
that's the base is that the baseline
that is even the baseline where is the
where is their model
um
yeah i don't i don't currently i don't
currently find it but you can just see
sort of the scale here
of what they're going for so this is
these are not small models but if you
make them sufficiently large you can see
the largest models they're not done
training yet
even
after they put sufficient or put uh
enormous amounts of resources through
them you can see they're not even not
even
the same ahead like the same advanced
inside of the training
so
yeah this
it is very promising i think this is
very promising direction to make use of
that
to make use of the html structure you
can see a little bit here so essentially
if you just put this as a prompt you can
have the model generate the alt text and
the image at the same time right it
interestingly chooses to put the alt
text in front like it it chooses to
generate the little description before
it generates the images which is
interesting you can also force it to
first generate the image by just putting
the source tag directly so then it needs
to generate the image and it's
interesting because the quality of the
images when you force it to generate
image before alt text
it it is a lot lower as you can see here
than if it just if you just let it
generate the image in which case it
chooses to generate the alt text first
you can do many things you can do image
in painting by masking out a portion of
the tokens of the image you have to mask
out entire tokens but still you can do
like crude image infilling you can do
conditional infilling by providing alt
text first and then do in filling
you can you can do
conditional generation by providing alt
text so the the like the
the possibilities are very very great
right here you can see this is infilling
conditional infilling and so on the
possibilities are great and remember
this is very particular data sets and
very particular cleaning methods of html
i believe if we extend this to even more
structure and so on maybe even take
cascading style sheets into account take
all of the structural elements of
websites into account title tags headers
footers and so on
this could be could be
really powerful
beyond the applications that we see
right here they can also do text pure
text modality data sets as we said
entity disambiguation by predicting
hyperlinks they also do get new
state-of-the-art in summarization in
zero shot summarization by simply
generating like the
they simply generate like the title or
the uh the meta tag the description tag
of the website uh so they give it a fake
website with the text they want to
summarize and they generate these tags
they do say for completeness below is an
example of a prompt that can do basic
summarization i did not find that prompt
anywhere so
yeah maybe i didn't i didn't look enough
or maybe lot tech screwed up where some
kind of a figure is
in any case i don't want to go too much
into the
results right here but i think the
direction of using that structured
content is pretty cool uh the new
the new objective is also pretty cool i
do criticize a little bit that these two
things are kind of decoupled from each
other like they could all be their own
paper uh and that's also something that
we talk about in the interview so in the
interview we're going to go briefly over
the model again
over the research process over what it
means what it could enable and uh
what difficulties there were and also
over the results which are extremely
extremely interesting i enjoyed the
interview a lot i hope you do too tell
me what you think of it and now i'll
leave it up for the interview thank you
very much and have fun
[Music]
welcome everyone today i have with me
armen agar janyan and i've practiced
that name 10 seconds ago and i i think i
got it down uh armin is the first author
of the cm3 paper welcome uh armin to the
channel
thank you for having me
so i i saw this paper and of course you
have like uh some big names here there's
lots of authors there's facebook ai
research um but still
like given all of that it was still
impressive like i was i was impressed by
the
what it could do and and sort of the
results it gave like it seems to be well
there's zero shot there's image
generation there is like a new objective
there's html in there um so there's
there seems to be a lot in one pot uh if
you if you gave the pitch right i i will
have made an introduction but if you
gave the pitch to the paper what is it
mainly about
i mean the goal here was kind of to have
a single multi-modal model that can do
everything yeah image generation image
captioning
um image infilling to even pure text
tests like summarization but mostly
focusing on this
zero shot setting specifically this
popping setting
and
how did you like were you where you this
is a very popular thing i think in the
last few years this came up maybe maybe
starting with something like gpt3 where
people could really say okay stuff is
possible zero shot if we train on large
enough data then came things like dali
and so on where you know we saw for the
first time okay maybe stuff is even
possible in other modalities than text
um this this goes even further this is
multi-modal
there have been a lot of other
approaches to multi-modal there is like
this this
rudolph even model i don't know if
you've seen that it goes like image to
text to image and so on and they all
work let's say with very cleaned up data
it's very you know i want text i want
images that go with the text which makes
sense
right how
do you
uh get how did you get the idea to use
let's say relatively unstructured html
uh for this like how did how did your
thought process go
until you came to this idea
so
usually there are pros and cons having
super strong alignment right so like big
dolly for example they have like a very
specific alignment of like uh you know
text on the left side and then you have
like 10 24 image tokens on the right
side right super strong alignment
and in general it's easy for the models
to kind of learn this type of single
alignment but then you're incredibly
limited on the prompting side and i
think it's prompting is i think it's
incredibly creative
um it's kind of if you have a general
model it takes a little bit of
creativity to extract out the prompt so
the key here is we don't want to have
any strict alignment uh in terms of the
modalities um so the goal was like what
is the weakest alignment that we can go
for that would still give us the ability
to prompt in non-trivial ways
um so actually this is kind of a
follow-up to an older paper that we
published it was just accepted in an ic
iclr actually which was this html paper
and uh the core idea of this paper is
that we argue that document structure is
really really important so what we did
there is we took bart bart large and
then we pretty much trained it on
uh just web data like minimized html
right
so minimal html is we pretty much do
multiple passes over the dom and take
out anything that we don't think is
semantically important
[Music]
so in that paper we showed really strong
results so for example for zero shot
summarization in in a structured
language like html this is pretty much
just generating the title right or
generating the meta tag where you know
the attribute is the headline right
in some sense we could exactly replicate
how cnn and daily mail was collected
which was they looked for headlines
right so in the prompt you can actually
describe the way that the data was
collected so we saw that there was some
rich structure available to be used um
in html so after dolly came out we
thought okay um there are some
fundamental restrictions with delhi so
the first one being the causal uh
approach so they train a decon or only
left to right model so in some sense you
can't do things like generate the text
given the image right just because of
the positioning of the image yeah it's
on the right side of the input right you
can't really do image infilling either
um which means conditioning on both the
prefix and postfix of the image it's not
working or you'd have to like train
specifically
one particular type of infilling right
you could you could rearrange stuff such
that you could infill one part but you
can't like dynamically infill something
exactly yeah so those were kind of the
first weaknesses uh that we saw there uh
the approach was very clever though
right so pretty much taking continuous
data discretizing it and just doing
sequence modeling it seems to work very
very well so the idea went that we could
kind of combine the two from the html
paper which was that
uh
you know document structure through html
is really important but let's also
encode images there and see if we can
recover something like dali yeah um
so here you're kind of looking at the
data that we collected so the data set
size is actually quite good i mean we're
around like the 200 billion tokens
which is a relatively good size if
you're training large models um
but one kind of downside that we have
here is because we don't have the strict
alignment we can't
artificially increase the amount of
images that we have available in the
documents yeah you actually look i think
we have 25 million unique images
um i don't know about dolly dolly was
trained on 400 million i don't know how
many of them are unique but regardless
they still have an order of magnitude
more images than you do right but then
we have the other benefits right which
is we're also training on the ton of
text so we can do a lot of text only
tasks and i think the rest of the paper
will show uh that you know we can do not
only text only tests but we're actually
competitive to t5 which is actually
really hard to do um and i can explain
why we think this is the case in a
little bit so the very first thing was
okay so now we can we kind of have this
data but html is also very localized
right like the title always comes first
yeah well it's in the head right or like
the meta tags always pop up first right
so if you want to generate meta tags or
generate title right condition on the
rest of the text it's kind of
non-trivial how you would do this in
decon or only setting yeah
and so
we kind of started thinking
you know there are multiple ways around
this right so the first thing is using
encoder decoder architecture right
and then with some masking you can kind
of recover this type of
bi-directionality
this is true but there are pros and cons
to this so encoder decoder only
architectures um they're really good for
fine tuning but they're not so good for
prompting is at least what we noticed um
and also training them is a little bit
more non-trivial so decoder only models
are quite nice because you get per token
generation
uh so you pretty much generate every
token uh for the source um whereas for
encoder decoder most of the time you're
generating i think like 15 is what burke
and like bart or like roberta do it's
all around that 15
um so most of the times you have to go
through the data multiple times
um for some reason they don't prompt
super well um
and the kind of the other big thing is
if you want to do score based prompting
it's kind of it's kind of hard to do
with the encoder decoder only
architecture right like if you want to
ask what's the log probability of this
sequence with the language model it's
kind of tough to do right um so we knew
that we wanted to go kind of this decon
only route so we introduced this new
objective that we called causal masking
and so the idea behind causal masking if
you want to scroll down i think there's
a
there's a
figure there
this one yeah so the idea there is uh
relatively straightforward right so
pretty much think of mass language
modeling uh where you place in the mask
but take the mask uh
and put the
put what the mass represents simply at
the very end of the sequence
um so if you do this you kind of get
it's very very simple right um but you
get a lot of the benefits which is you
still get per token generation uh you
optionally allow for bi-directionality
which is actually a really really big
thing to have right
and the other thing that we noticed is
that depending on the setting prompting
versus fine tuning the size of the mask
is really important so for fine-tuning
localized information is really
important
you want to have a lot of small masks
for prompting we saw kind of the
opposite which is you want to have very
very few masks but they can be very long
so the strategy that we use here is
for every document we sample from a
poisson distribution centered around one
um so you know the majority of times
right and we clip it to one so if you
get zero it becomes one right so
majority of times you're only going to
get a single mask right over 50 of the
time you're only going to get a single
mask uh and then you pick you you
uniformly uh sample a subset of the
document of any size
um and you can and you kind of place
that on the end so you get these very
very long kind of infilling naturally
and so this objective turned out to be
quite strong
um so it's competitive to language
modeling in the sense that when you get
per token generation our perplexities
were not that much higher than just the
language modeling objective um you get
optional bi-directionality whenever you
want it right you can score
probabilities
uh of sequences super super easily um so
we're kind of going all in on this
objective and so we have some follow-up
work looking at
um causal masked uh scaling loss for
text so this is some occurring work that
we have now um so we're pushing heavily
on this
um so the general argument that we're
trying to build is that you know if
you're doing language modeling uh
decriminally language modeling you
should be doing causal mass the language
so that's kind of like yeah i mean i was
i was
it is intuitively a good trade-off so i
think here you make the case if if i
interpret this correctly that this word
nationalist right here is really
important to fill in this mask and and
if if it were just sort of left to right
it would be very difficult to fill this
in yet
since you move it to the end right and
and
the model has to extra learn kind of to
uh keep
these these tokens in context to sort of
realize you know what's there so it has
to waste kind of some extra memory uh to
to remember the context of each of the
mask tokens and so on but um
yeah i i think it is very intuitive it's
also a good trade-off between i want to
say
left to right has
at least for you know most there are
right to left languages but for left to
right languages left to right objective
actually makes sense right that that is
how we generate language you know when
we write it down so there is something
to left to right that i was never happy
there are other other approaches like
xlnet or so they were saying well we
just train on all possible paths right
of decoding like all possible sequence
of masking out tokens and it was
it was never really satisfying because i
always thought well there is something
to left to right
however
sometimes as you say it's really
important to know what's after and uh
and and
i think this is like a really good
trade-off
yeah like specifically in this example
right like in the zero shot prompting
case right like let's say we want to tag
nationalist with some entity link right
um if it appears beforehand in the
sequence there's no way to prompt a
language model to generate like an
entity link before the entity appears
right yeah uh
so that was kind of another reason that
we had because like i said like html
data is very localized right like in
wikipedia this this a tag which
represents the entity link always
appears before the entity yeah either uh
we have the option of you know training
two models right one left to right one
right to left um
um or you can kind of do this kind of
clever rotation of the document um you
said uh yeah the excel net approach is
definitely interesting um which is you
know having different permutations of
the source document but like you said i
think there's a lot of inductive biased
um for left to right
which is why i think left to right
models are kind of de facto now
is there
just just from my understanding is there
a reason behind these arrows like why do
the arrows like are like double arrows
then there's a line and there's like a
double arrow again like is this does
that have a specific meaning and here
the arrows are only here
yeah so errors pretty much uh was the
tokens that you actually generate so
okay the language model you're
generating every token in the map so you
go like this okay i see i see yeah
because i was i was like okay
is there some meaning but yes there is
and this shows that in the mask language
model objective you only actually
generate very small number of tokens and
you you wouldn't even get like a loss
for the other tokens yeah exactly
um you said before
that uh you had a certain number of
tokens right with and you said well
that's actually good or bad for you know
that's actually in a good order for
language modeling yet a special thing
about your model is that images are also
tokens
uh you you you push images through a vq
vqgan encoder right
um
which is pre-trained
and these image these just become
tokens in
uh
in in whatever sequence
do you and this results obviously in
larger data because some of it is images
so you say you have a terabyte of data
in this data set which is obviously way
larger than for example
a text only data set do you find there
is a difference
like do you find the number of tokens is
really what matters in the size of the
data or is there a qualitative
difference between image data and text
data even though both are tokens
um
yeah so there's a couple ways to
approach this so the the very first
thing is that modeling
and i think we mentioned this quickly in
the paper but modeling image tokens
versus text tokens it's quite different
actually so for like text usually
follows like textual tokens follow like
a zip fiend distribution right
whereas i think in appendix we have a
figure it's pretty much uniform for
images yeah
so there's different
like uh in terms of the distributions
that you have to predict they're
actually quite different so we saw a
little bit of challenges and we saw some
kind of weird behavior during training
we didn't mention this in the paper but
the one weird behavior that we saw was
that there were uh regimes during the
training like parts of the training that
only optimized for text so on our image
evaluations like it pretty much would be
flat and then there were times that it
was quite the opposite where you know
images would be being optimized for but
text kind of stayed flat so we don't
really have explanations for why this is
happening um i think there needs to be
future like scaling laws looking at
multimodal sequence modeling unless
multimodal i'm not just talking about
like images and like natural language
text i meant like you can even include
code as a different modality right yeah
um
so the scaling laws there i think are a
little bit different than what we're
used to with the text um the reason for
using tokens is purely because of a
compute thing right so uh you know we're
given some amount of gpus right for some
amount of times
uh so what we do is we take the number
of
uh tokens that we have we take the
amount of compute that we have and try
to find the largest size model that we
can train which is kind of an
optimization problem to find the largest
architecture
um so that's kind of why we used a
number of tokens as the as the guiding
principle i mean it it seems to also
align with what others yeah for example
this rudolph
paper so that it seems to be a common
approach to lift images into like the
space of textual tokens which is
i guess a bit surprising because a
couple of years ago no one would have
gone that route even if you even if you
were to inject images into
a sequence model you'd probably inject
like a single vector right um and so
i've i find that to be
well a bit surprising but also
uh yeah it seems appropriate that an
image could be expressed in something
like a sequence of tokens it's it's just
a bit i'm not too big of a fan of how
this is currently done because the
tokens they also
like they already they seem to be a bit
localized in the image and so on like i
don't i don't i think there's like a
better and i think there's a better way
if if you're a human you're not that's
not really what you do with an image you
see more like like the different layers
maybe or or what's there in any case i
was surprised by these scaling plots
like these are these are brutal like
this is like we scale it up and it just
like the the the loss goes down for the
largest model it seems like you're
nowhere near done right
like just this just so you you said you
had some different experiences during
training
uh yet also i think in the paper
somewhere you you hinted at well we
didn't really see any pathologies uh so
what's like what's
what was the the process like you had
the data you trained the thing did it
immediately work
um
it took a little bit of hand holding to
work especially the the 13 billion
framer model took a little bit of hand
holding to work so a lot of times the
pathologies we see is are things like
gradient underfloor overflow
gradient explosions happen although
they're more they usually happen in much
bigger models like the 100 billion scale
um but the surprising thing was that we
almost used exactly the same hyper
parameters
as this paper that came out from
vestorinos group
um
so the surprising thing is it kind of
just worked out of the box apart from
having to tune i think we tuned like
learning rate um
we had to tune weight decay and batch
size apart from tuning those things it
just worked almost straight out of the
box
and what you said is actually correct
which is if you look at the large model
it's actually not done training
so
the good news is once once cm3 is
released we're going to release the the
checkpoint that we use for this model um
uh i think the model that we have now is
continuing training so we'll really use
that one too so
uh people will be able to play around
with both
excellent
but one thing i'd like to point out is
that the multi-modal scaling laws are a
little bit different than text scaling
laws um one thing
seems to be that skill plays a slightly
larger role
um
in multi-modal than it does in text um
so i i think the qual the quantitative
thing that we saw is that if you looked
at the data efficiency jumps between
like uh
i'm forgetting the exact numbers but
like like let's make them up like the
1.3 billion model in the 13 billion
model from from vesta's paper
and the data efficiency there let's say
it was like the larger model was five
times more efficient in terms of data
so uh in order to reach the same
perplexity it would need five times less
data
using these same exact models we saw
that in the multi-modal case it was 10x
so there was always almost a
two times difference for some reason
uh and that's why i think it's really
important to kind of chase these
multi-modal scale laws and fundamentally
understand what's going on here
um there's a lot of unknowns here
when you say
we had to do a little bit of
hand-holding what does that what does
that even mean in these large models
like can you afford to restart training
or or is it more like you know you have
checkpoint checkpoint and then something
goes wrong and you go back to the last
checkpoint and you do something there
like what what is what does the process
of training these very large models look
like
it's just really really tedious so one
of the main things is um
you know whenever you have a ton of
nodes that you're running there's
infrastructure issues that pop up right
so like if one gpu goes down right then
then all of training is positive rates
so infrastructure issues are kind of a
big thing and we have some automated
systems in place to take care of that um
other things are like
um for example like uh we didn't set a
high enough warm-up period in the
beginning
so we saw that we actually had to pause
training increase the warm-up load up
the last checkpoint and go there um
and so we also kind of tuned learning
rate a little bit as training goes on um
although with the large models i think
it might have been just a handful of
times um so failure do you always have
like multiple models running ahead and
then you choose the one that looks best
or is it really like you change and you
train one model and you see how it
develops
yeah because of the computer it's one
model so it really comes down to
intuition
um so both mike lewis and naman goyal
who are on the paper have trained these
really really big models before um so
they had a ton of great intuition about
how to get things to work
um
in terms of these very large models
yeah
cool i mean yeah i'm excited and it is
very cool that you you actually are
going to release uh these things i think
people
will love to play around with them uh
for
in order to do
now the the tasks
uh
you tackled some tasks how did you
decide which there are some natural
tasks let's say there there are some
that are more
you know you have to come up with
something um did you have some targets
of tasks that you want to tackle or was
it more like the model came first and
then you you sat down and saw what can
you actually do with it and what not
like and what worked and were there also
tasks that you tried that maybe didn't
work at all
yeah
um yeah that's a great question so i i
think at the beginning of the project
the the push was really to have a single
model uh
that can do any image task in the zero
shot case
and so kind of the story that we built
around it is can we describe all the
tasks that we're interested in um
through some prompt through some html
prompt even before we train the models
so we came up with the time right
and some some problems were very
complicated like a style transfer for
one one right so you can have an image
that has a picture of the mountains in
the summer um and then you have another
image tag that says the same picture but
in the winter and then you ask them all
to predict the image tokens right so you
can get this kind of zero shot style
transfer yeah so you have some kind of
complex prompts um
so some of them didn't work some of them
only worked at scale and we can kind of
go go through this um specifically like
one thing is that like the captioning
only worked at scale so the 13 billion
model was the only model that could
caption well and the captioning you go
mainly with the alt text of the image
alter the title either one yeah um but
like the figure that you're on now i
think is kind of interesting so
we can
kind of get unconditional image
generation by just asking the model to
generate
a sequence of tokens after the image tag
right
so we saw one interesting behavior is
that the model for some reason almost
always wanted to first generate the alt
text before generating the image um for
it was actually easier to condition on
the on the text before generating an
image than doing this type of freeform
generation
when you say wanted to it that's just
what it did
yeah like when you when you sampled did
you like i mean this
when you say one or two it could also be
that in the internet humans most of the
time write alt first and then the source
yeah so we actually looked into this so
uh
a lot of text does have alt um but it's
around like i want to say like 70 to 80
mark if i recall correctly so it
wouldn't explain why the model almost
always wants to generate alt text now
the the theory that we kind of have is
that without alt text you have much
higher perplexities for images
so the model you know even because
because we're doing like sampling right
so it's going to pick out high
probability low perplexity tokens yeah
which most of the case means picking out
the alt
just because it appears so often
um so that could be it but uh overall i
think if you look at these images
they're they're rather like they're
semi-coherent especially the ones
conditioned on the text
um
and the same thing i think you see with
you can kind of force the model not to
generate the alt text by giving a prompt
and generate the image tokens
immediately
and do you do you think
so the the like the vqgan tokens
naturally they are predicted as one
right um
there is there's some encoder they're
not as as far as i understand they're
not in the
image encoder that makes the tokens
they're not predicted other aggressively
so there's no
inherent sequence nature to these tokens
could that be
like some sort of a reason why there's
also a difference because text naturally
is sequential whereas these tokens the
only thing they have is they're they're
kind of localized but there's no
inherent sequential nature
yeah that's true there isn't for v2v
again there isn't
something explicit but though i think
the way that the layers are constructed
you do still get some implicit
dependencies across the world tokens and
so i think this is what the transformer
is kind of pulling apart here yeah um
yeah and to be honest i think there's
still a lot of work to be done on the
discretizing images front so
uh
one thing about like dtv again is that
it blurs a lot of fine detail so like
human faces um in our case this is kind
of good because it's privacy preserving
you're not going to generate like a
person's face um unless it's a really
really popular and like close-up face
um case it kind of worked out but in the
future i think we need to get much much
higher fidelity
um image tokens if we think that the way
of doing things is to treat everything
as a token
of course i think there are a ton of new
approaches that are not token based i
think glide was fantastic from open ai
the diffusion models are doing great
generative work
but if you wanna
if you wanna maintain the same um
benefits of generative models um so
being able to generate trivially uh
being able to compute a lot of
probabilities i think tokens are
probably the easiest way to go
and one thing is you can naturally
increase the resolution of tokens images
just by increasing how many tokens you
use per image
so in some sense if you have enough
compute you can
scale up to arbitrary resolutions right
yeah i mean yeah down to probably
probably you could at some point get
more
more tokens than pixels i wouldn't know
what what that would mean but
um
i guess the resolution isn't even
limited by the resolution of the image
itself
so there's there's this this interesting
thing you can do as you said in filling
uh by letting the model generate sort of
middle
tokens now
you i mean you could probably do
arbitrary infilling but you have to have
like multiple mask tokens so i guess the
the natural thing to do is just to
infill
uh since the tokens kind of go
left to right top to bottom is to infill
one of these stripes which you've
demonstrated right here um
sorry did you did you try infilling like
arbitrary things or or was this sort of
the natural thing to do
yeah so actually because of our
objective because we sample the number
of masks right yeah um you can actually
mask out like five six seven masks yeah
and it still work um i don't think there
was any specific reason that we stuck to
masking out a single thing
um i'm sure it would work with multiple
as well
i mean if you like if you were to if you
were to infill let's say you know if i
infill a square like this
um and it covers sort of multiple token
lines this would already result in like
if it covers three token lines it would
already result in like three mask tokens
right
so yeah i mean there is there is some
with just with the the sequential nature
uh but i think that can be can be worked
around so um what here we see
so left is a source image then you mask
out something in the middle um then you
also give the ground truth which is here
on the right and then there's one model
that does infilling unconditional so
just looking at the image and then there
is one model that does it conditionally
and the conditional is uh conditioned
with this thing right here as the the
alt text so you understand
okay so understand it correctly um
i was yeah i mean i was surprised for
example by this one right here this uh
the park bench because obviously if you
see the
the
model that does infilling conditionally
it can do it quite well
however the unconditional one it kind of
warps the bench or something like this
like
it's it's a bit
i'm not i'm not sure the
unconditionality
has something much to do with it because
there is no
this doesn't look like natural you know
you know what i mean a little bit
like yeah
this shouldn't be like
just because it's not conditioned on it
if it's not conditioned on text i would
expect it to be maybe a red bench right
or or something you know something uh
that is conceivable in nature but is not
according to the text like there is an
ambiguity of what's behind the mask
however here it really seems to degrade
in performance when you don't give it
the text
yeah so so one theory that we kind of
had here um is that the the model needs
to understand the continuing
continuation of the the horizontal lines
right
that requires some semantic
understanding that this is for example
uh a bench right and actually if you
look at the the masked out input the
horizontal lines are not completely
horizontal so the bottom of the bench is
at a different angle than
the top of the bench so i think the
model has a tough time understanding the
the high level semantic content of the
image which is fixed by feeding in text
yeah
now i think of course if you have i
think if you have a larger model that's
trained for longer with a higher
resolution uh this probably should not
be an issue
um but vqv again it blurs out a lot of
things number one yeah uh number two
it's um
just if you change the tokens even a
little bit the the blurring aspect
happens very very
quickly with vq va again
compared to for example the vq va from
dali
which requires more tokens so 1024
tokens versus the 256 we use here um but
uh it's more direct in some sense yeah
so yeah i think the main thing here is
just that you need to get some like high
level
semantic information about what's going
on in the image
um and it's hard to do if you're only
looking at like the vqp
gam tokens yeah
okay i mean that makes makes sense you
go on and you have some examples of
uh conditional image generation so on
the left side here is a prompt and then
you sample
images from that
with the same technique right you give
the alt text and then you sample the
image so the
the avocado chair is is like forever
going to be to stick in history right i
think
that's just that's just a given um was
there one was there something that
surprised you uh with um conditional
image generation
yeah so the the models are are quite
good at actually generating something
that's somewhat coherent so yeah for
example like the red car you can see it
generates you know two red cars that one
looks like a truck or a tractor um
sometimes the model tries to cheat and
and generate
something that's easy for example
the in the case that it doesn't generate
a car at all it just generates mountains
right just because landscapes are easier
to generate um the other thing that we
saw kind of tough compared to dali is
you know the data that we used only came
from wikipedia or common crawl news so
none of it was
fictional in some sense right like we
don't have any like art yeah um so
like our images always try to be as
non-fictional as possible which is it
that's weird if you try to give it um
like really fantasy based prompts yeah
so that's kind of one downside actually
this is one criticism i have
of the evaluation that we did for the
fid matrix which is a way to measure uh
you know the quality of images which is
we actually took the table from glide
for the fid numbers on the conditional
generation uh one thing was is that ms
coco is all like
almost all non-fiction
uh like non-fantasy images so this is
really
like
it's under representing dolly so i think
if you casted the wider net here and had
something that included a wider array
uh a bigger distribution of images i
think dolly's results here would be uh
much much stronger
yeah which is why i think we're kind of
comparable our largest model is
comparable to dolly on ms coco but in
terms of image generation it's not as
good um on the like the fantasy front at
all
[Music]
you did you did discuss a little bit you
also said you had you you saw
sub-sampled uh web data and and and you
cited some concerns as well um but there
is also quality issue with sort of the
wider you cast the net
uh the sort of more the quality goes
down i guess the alt the alt tags
quality go down whether or not the
images even have alt tags whether or not
they're ads or something like this
what were
like why did you limit to this subset of
the data and not bigger or smaller
i think at the beginning we had some
ethical concerns if
like
like i said we have very weak alignment
so you can prompt with anything right
yeah we had some ethical concerns about
images that you can generate if you were
just trained on all of common chrome
so we try to think about what are like
large-scale datasets that we can get
that are somewhat filtered uh wikipedia
is definitely one of them um but even
then actually wikipedia itself has a
gender bias and i think this is a new i
think other papers have shown this
before and common crawl news which
probably is not going to have the the
terrible content that we don't want to
pick up yeah
so we kind of picked those two and it
was okay at the scale that we wanted to
so we stuck with those two
um
but
yeah i think i i think it's hard i i
don't know what the solution is like the
the leon 400 million data set that was
released
um i don't know if you've heard of it uh
but uh
this data set i think there was a
critique paper written in like a month
about it right that showed that it was
like a highly highly problematic data
set
so in terms of the ethical approach i'm
not really sure what the right answer is
for collecting at scale
um there are tricks you can do right so
like if you look at the cc 100 data set
that facebook collected they use this
trick that you know they train a
language model on wikipedia and then use
it to score a common crawl and then take
only like medium complex things
so you could probably do something like
this here yeah
i i question the efficacy just because
very large models they only need to see
a data point a couple times in order to
pick it up
um
so
i think there's like some very
fundamental engineering work that that's
being done and for scaling up these data
sets to like
um
like uh trillions of tokens essentially
um
images
yeah i mean
i guess it casts much wider questions
such as
uh you know i as a human i'm perfectly
capable of going to 4chan and and seeing
kind of the worst of humanity and it
doesn't instantly make me like
you know
i don't know a terrible
terrible like it doesn't what make me
want to repeat everything or something
like this and and there's there's
various considerations like shouldn't we
be able to build model that also ingests
stuff but
kind of may also a bit
distinguish between things like if the
models are able to distinguish it might
help them to ingest more of this
critical data on the other hand i can
absolutely understand that
especially if you're the maker of a
model you don't want your model to
output
you know that i think that's why for
example open ai keeps such a tight grip
on on gpt3
if you want to build anything with it
right you have to go through approval
processes and whatnot
and uh it's it's uh yeah it's
i think it's tricky topic i also don't
know
what exactly to do i'm happy that
there are models that are
filtered like say unfiltered data i'm
happy that there also exists models that
aren't
um
yeah i i think the
maybe the
sort of the
let's say diversity makes
is is probably the best so you can
always choose which one you wanna you
wanna use i don't know sorry this is
just around by now
um
you do have some sorry go ahead
i was gonna say
with respect to what you're saying
there's the solution doesn't necessarily
have to lie on the language model side
yeah um so one thing is you can think of
language modeling as just pure density
estimation over tokens right
so if you're doing that like of course
you're to model like 4chan for example
right but it's up to your generative
sampling strategy to remove that part of
the density and only sample from you
know parts of the density estimation
that you know are safe for example
and so we're actually seeing i think a
lot of movement from you know having a
singular model that does generative work
uh and to having like multiple models so
a great example is like dolly right so
they do density estimation over you know
text and image tokens right uh but the
way they generate images is they sample
like 128 candidates and or or whatever
number of candidates and then they use
clip
a secondary model to kind of
uh select in some sense the mode of the
slice of the density yeah right
and so something
probably
similarly can be done here like a great
example is like take codecs for example
right i think in the codex paper what
they do is they generate a ton of
samples and then they re-rank the
samples
uh in terms of perplexity so average
probability and then they take the mode
so essentially the exact mode of that uh
density estimation right yeah so one
thing to argue is that you know you
could you could train language models
that do pure density estimation over all
the text that we have and then have
smarter generation algorithms that are
able to select
subsets of that density that are safe
um so like you said like for for in
terms of research i think there's
there's pros and cons to having
unfiltered and filtered models but
that's kind of the way i've been
thinking about it recently yeah and it's
probably a good approach because the
sort of the handle we have on let's say
discriminative models like clip is a lot
larger than the handles we have really
on on generative models like
yeah the only the only handler really we
have there is is kind of data
yeah
um you also do some experiments on
text pure i want i don't want to say
pure text data because it's more than
that right it's entity disambiguation
entity linking and so on now is that
purely a
result of the fact like of you use
wikipedia as a data source and wikipedia
is essentially it's not really only text
it's kind of a huge entity link and
database
is that is that kind of is it fair to
say that it works really well because
you use wikipedia as data or is there
something more to it
yeah no that's exactly it so actually uh
um there's this work that we said in
this paper a couple times the genre
paper from the genre paper i think the
paper is called other regressive entity
linking or entity disambiguation so the
idea there was exactly that which is you
know you
if you take all of wikipedia and then
you train the language model
um that uh tries to predict entity link
post entity um you get a model that does
really really good entity linking right
so in some sense
the genre objective was a subset of our
much more general objective yeah right
and it's not too surprising we beat out
genre just because our models are bigger
um in the in our fine tuning case but
the really really cool thing i think was
that we can do this the zero shot
which is exactly what i shown in the
first figure um you know if you mask out
the entity if you know that you want
this entity
you want to disambiguate this entity you
can place a mask there with this a tag
right
and then our model will fill in what it
thinks the disambiguation is
yeah so
that's kind of cool uh i couldn't find
any
like zero shot bass lines like this so i
think this is kind of the first paper to
do this
um type of zero shot entity linking and
disambiguation
and so i mean you also have you just
have other tasks like uh summarization
uh we also didn't look at the con like
the the uh the alt text generation and
so on is there one result that we didn't
talk about that you wanna highlight in
particular like what maybe one surprised
you the most or so
yeah so so the captioning one was
interesting i think we can look at that
yeah so the captioning is this is pretty
much the duel of dolly right so what
we're doing is saying okay you know give
now that you have an image generate the
alt text for me given the image right so
in some sense we can exactly describe
the captioning task in html which is
again kind of solidifies the argument
that you want some level of document
structure for prompting um so the
results are are quite uh
good actually at least from a semantic
level so one problem is that we don't
actually
generate in the style of uh i think ms
coco here
um so we didn't report like blue four
uh numbers or like the standard numbers
but if you look at the semantic uh
uh similarity using bert score the
the cm3 captioning with clip as a
re-ranker is actually a very very strong
baseline
and so you can kind of see the style
here is weird it tries to explicitly
state what type of airplane it is yeah
uh
but that's kind of an interesting
behavior um so i think definitely at
scale
uh you know you could get a single model
that i think could be competitive with
ms coco
uh with caption only models uh if you do
things like increase the resolution of
the tokenized images um i think scale is
really important here so if you just
scale up
um so that you have a similar amount of
samples that are trained using ms coco
you you've said this a couple of times
now this sort of um you know with scale
we could beat this or that or
um and i i guess you see this work a
little bit as a maybe a signpost you
know to like later work that actually
achieves this scale do you think the
scale you're talking about the scale at
which you know that this is competitive
with on ms coco uh where the image
generation is competitive with dali um
do you think that scale is currently
achievable or is it so large that it's
kind of well you know we we need
entirely new hardware
yeah i think it is achievable so uh let
me tell you about the result that we
just got a couple of days back that's
not in the paper here so
one one reason that we also changed uh
chase this kind of multi-modal setup is
because we're interested or at least i'm
very personally interested in the
grounding aspect of language
um so we kind of define grounding as can
you improve
uh
document level perplexity on text by
extra conditioning on images so that's
one uh
kind of way to measure grounding the
other way to measure grounding is we
call it symmetrical grounding so what
you do is uh given uh
pretty much given a a piece of text
generate an image from that piece of
text and then condition on that image
generate back that piece of text right
and i look at the perplexity differences
between the two texts and that will give
you the informational content of that
image that is generated right so you can
measure grounding that way the
unfortunate thing is that even the 13
billion parameter model that we have
here
did doesn't ground
but if you look at the scaling laws
um from you know or i think our 100
million perennial molecule or 13 billion
parameter model around the 60 billion
mark is where we'll see grounding in
this setup okay
linear plot
so our expectation is that if you scale
this up to 60 billion that you should be
able to achieve i think language image
grounding which is kind of a cool result
that i think a lot of people have been
chasing here um and that's it it's
insane that you can make these
predictions right this is like this is
something i think in machine learning is
something new uh because right now
no one could tell the most people could
tell was like gpt3 is going to be like
somewhat better than gpt2 but now you're
you're able and you know i i am
confident that this is a you know maybe
it might be whatever 50 or 80 billion
parameters but
you can actually make these predictions
which is which is
you know it's it's cool like i'm amazed
by this
yeah i definitely don't think we're
going to be like the order of magnitude
off right yeah so so i i think with the
100 billion parameter 100 billion or 175
billion like gpt3 size we can get very
very non-trivial behavior
um to the point of being competitive
across all tasks
um
and i i think the future in general is
having a single multi-modal model
um that can prompt an instructable way
kind of like construct gpt but with all
modalities
um so i think that's kind of the north
star that everyone is chasing right now
um but i think we have a good uh
i think we have a solid base for this
work
um
but yeah i think the captioning
surprised me and one thing that i want
to call out here is that it only worked
at the 13 billion scale i might have
mentioned this earlier so there are
fundamental stepwise changes in behavior
from scaling up the model it's not
something smooth right so
something that a 13 billion model can do
with something that uh you know like a
2.7 billion model will not be able to do
at all so you won't it's just going to
generate random stuff
um so yeah it's interesting to see what
the next you know stepwise changes in
behavior will be if you scale this up
um
[Music]
with respect to
the html right
that you use which is i i thought it was
it was pretty cool because it is data
that is you know so available
and your argument is a little bit that
if you clean the html too much right
these other these other data sets they
just pull out the text content maybe the
image they try to align it and so on you
know if you clean that up there's so
much structure missing right you're
missing on all of this valuable
information
yeah you also do cleaning right you do
quite a lot of of html cleaning you say
somewhere up here in in the data section
uh we strip this we strip that any any
sort of non
non whatever elements we strip out uh
all headers all footers copyrights forms
dialog boxes
we merge consecutive div elements and so
on can the same argument be made against
you
saying well you're losing so much of the
structure there's so much information
there like why are you doing this do you
think there is a valid direction to go
in
actually taking in even more context of
these html documents
yeah so
there are different constraints here
right so one thing that i mentioned is
that we can only
uh
model x amount of tokens right 300
billion tokens for example right so if
the majority of those tokens right like
i think the average document is like
95 of the document we removed
so yeah in some still right even though
even though you're the ones that remove
way less than the other ones
yeah so so in some sense do do we want
to model every single token so in the
case that you have infinite compute sure
um but here there's kind of a min max
problem that you have to solve right
which is you want to kind of
you want to maximize the amount of
semantic information that is available
while minimizing the amount of tokens
that you have right um and and this is
kind of complex to do so i think we
found a good enough
balance of the two
um like in most cases like you don't
want to repeat the same copyright like
400 million times right
i mean there's there's probably a lot of
information in the fact that jquery is
imported in this website right
right so um things like that but we also
do things that might break document
structure like the merging elements
right there's probably something there
as to why the person has multiple div
elements right
regardless we remove it the other thing
that we remove is attributes
so we remove all the attributes except
those that are structured so like open
graph schema i think twitter has a like
a structure graph
as well
and the reason there was that the
attributes were just first of all they
were way too long most of the time
and they were not informationally rich
enough
so
you kind of have to balance compute here
with how much uh structural information
you want to maintain yeah
so there's no fundamental reason to use
html right it's just something that's
there right there's i mean for example
you can use markdown as well right and
you can kind of recover a lot of the
same things right like generating the
title you can do in markdown right
hyperlinks you can do in markdown right
um so maybe the future direction is you
know explicitly
codifying this min max problem right and
coming up with the document structure
that
the document structure is describing the
minimal set of tokens
um
so maybe that's you know that's a pure
engineering project as well um
but
yeah when you when you think of html and
the dom
it is
a tree right
which is different from a linear
sequence uh do you do you think there is
do you think
there's value in treating the tree as a
tree do you think it's mainly a
limitation of the models we have they go
let's say
like see token by token or left to right
or something like this
do you think you know maybe it's still
good to treat it as a sequence because
there's text in there and text is left
to right like what keeps us from
building tree based models which would
be much more appropriate for something
like this
yeah so
one thing about transformers is it seems
that they can learn the inductive bias
of the data fairly well and it's not
necessarily encoded
so my argument to this is that usually
for these large scale
runs the best thing is just to keep it
as simple as
possible mostly just because they're
risky right you get one chance
but the other reason is that
transformers are actually highly capable
of picking up this type of
structure yeah so this isn't in the
paper but we looked at the tension
scores and then you can you can see very
clearly that the model knows what are
like boundaries between html elements
um for example but i
but again there's also a ton of work to
be done as well so like some exciting
work is i think you also interviewed
like opher
for the alibi work right like
that work is really clever right because
it introduces an explicit inductive bias
that the further away token is probably
less likely that you are to look at it
and gets rid of the need for you know
positional uh representations yeah
so you can imagine like an extension of
alibi here that would directly encode
the tree-like uh structure right
um so there's a ton of work to be done
here another other thing is we were
we didn't do too much for the images
right like in terms of attending like
the positional representations for
images are different than of text right
so future work should consider like
uh specifically
uh embedding images in such a way that
you know you maintain locality of
positions right
so this is all stuff that needs to be
done in the future as well um but that
being said i think if you have enough
compute these models can learn anything
it mostly becomes an efficiency angle
yeah going forward
so about this paper so what would i
have a bit of a trouble with is you know
too many things in one paper which in
this case is
it's this idea of using html and so on
although there was a previous paper uh
of that but then there's also the new
loss um and so on have you like tested
the new loss on pure text generation uh
something like this would would this be
like can you can you parse out sort of
what what the different things
contribute to the the success of these
models
yeah and that's a great criticism of the
paper actually so fundamentally i think
if we
wanted to do this like the proper
science way this would be like four or
five papers um just teasing things apart
but
at the same time when you're training
these large language models ablation
studies are pretty much impossible right
no one has much compute to do these
ablation studies but the answer is yes
so we're looking at causal mass scaling
laws for text only this is a project
that we're working on we've trained a
code model
um
using the causal mass objective um
that's you know outperforming
i think both google and codecs have
similar sizes while being able to have a
bi-directional
uh
bi-directional option
so um there are a couple teams within
facebook that are trying out this
objective with some success um so
uh there will be future work about this
excellent
and apart from
what you just mentioned and scale what's
sort of next in this in this direction
are you like what are you excited about
maybe it's not even you working on it
but what kind of
is your is exciting stuff that's
happening
so one thing is figuring out a way to
have higher fidelity so
the question to ask here is how do you
represent continuous data in the
discrete domain
um
and i don't think we're there yet
right um so that's some fundamental work
that needs to move forward
the other thing that i'm kind of
interested in looking is
um can we start joining more modalities
right so like hubert that also came from
from uh facebook
had uh
speech tokens right
um very simple i think they use k-means
i might be wrong though uh
just to find discrete tokens for speech
so imagine that you have a single model
that has video images
you know text yeah
right speech everything kind of put into
one right like what level of grounding
and what level of zero shot prompting
can you get here
um and i think a lot of people are kind
of chasing this at the bigger companies
um i'm kind of excited about that on the
analysis front i think there's still a
lot of unknowns about transformers like
fundamentally we're still using the four
year old uh implementation right yeah
the the only difference is just
pre-layer norm right from the original
transformer
so
i think better fundamentally
understanding um
transformers and i have some qualms with
scaling laws like i don't think
perplexity is necessarily the measure
that we should be using
so internally uh we've been discussing
like what does like memory based scaling
laws look like so if you use memory as
the fundamental unit of transformers
what do those scaling laws look like
right
um so there's some more fundamental work
to be done there
um and the other thing is bridging fine
tuning and prompting performance so far
it's kind of orthogonal which is you
know if you want to get a better
fine-tuning model you have to do
something that will hurt prompting and
vice versa
so figuring out like is it just like
is it just because we don't have like
bi-directional
like masks
is that one is it because we only mask
for like
causal models and upper triangular
matrix is there something more
fundamental there i think kind of
peeling that apart and figuring what's
going on there is kind of important too
um
but i think we're very early on i think
mo i think this year is going to be the
year of multimodal yeah i know they kind
of kick stuff off so i'm kind of excited
to see what other groups are working on
it seems like it yeah um is there
anything
else about the paper or the research
direction you want to shout out you want
people to know that we haven't mentioned
so far
yeah i mean we'll be releasing all this
code really really soon uh we're just
waiting on some internal approvals so
people will get to play around with it
um i think we'll release three billion
model but the 13 billion model is the
one that really shines yeah so if people
get that running i think it's really
cool i've spent hours just playing
around with it it's nice
what does it what does it take to
like just to forward propagate what's
like the minimal configuration
um
[Music]
so with the recent deep speed stuff that
was released for inference i'm not
really sure because i think they said
that you can use one gpu for like a 6.7
billion model yeah so if you do model
parallelism i think you need two gpus
but if like
without that just give us a ballpark you
know what what would it what would it be
like forward propping through this model
yeah so one thing is you could do it on
the cpu if you have a strong enough cpu
but but for for inference i think
what i used was four v 100s yeah a model
parallel
so
uh less than a node
cool excellent well armin thank you so
much for being here this was really cool
um really value the like also the kind
of behind the scenes in insights we got
here
and yeah i hope to see you again very
soon with even like cm
four
thank you for having me
excellent
[Music]
you